so let's say that we've got the
polynomial 16 X to the third plus 24 x
squared plus 9x now what I'd like you to
do is pause the video and see if you can
factor this polynomial completely now
let's work through it together so the
first thing that you might notice is
that all of the terms are divisible by X
so we can actually factor out an X so
let's do that and actually if we look at
these coefficients it looks like let's
see it looks like they don't have any
common factors other than one so it
looks like the the largest monomial that
we can factor out is just going to be an
X so let's do that let's factor out an X
so then this is going to be x times when
you factor out an X from 16x to the
third you're going to be left with 16x
squared and then plus 24x and then plus
9 now this is starting to look
interesting so let me just rewrite it
this is going to be x times this part
over here looks interesting because when
I see the 16x squared this looks like a
perfect square
let me write it out 16x squared that's
the same thing as 4x 4x squared and then
we have a 9 over there which is clearly
a perfect square that is 3 squared 3
squared and when we look at this 24x we
see that it is 4 times 3 times 2 and so
we can write it as let me write it this
way so this is going to be plus 2 times
4 times 3x so let me make it so 2 times
4 times 3 times 3x now why did I why did
I take the trouble why did I take the
trouble of writing everything like this
because we see that it fits the pattern
for a perfect square what do I mean by
that well in previous videos we saw that
if you have something of the form ax
plus B and you were to square it you're
going to get a x squared plus 2a
be X plus B squared and we have that
form right over here this is the ax
squared let me do the same color the ax
squared ax squared we have the B squared
you have the B squared and then you have
the two a B X 2 a B X right over there
so this section this entire section we
can rewrite as being we know what a and
B are a is four and B is 3 so this is
going to be ax so 4 X plus 4 X plus B
which we know to be 3 that whole thing
that whole thing squared and now we
can't forget this X out front so we have
that X out front and we're done we have
just factored this we have just factored
this completely we could write it as x
times 4 X plus 3 and then write out and
then say times 4 X plus 3 or we could
just write x times the quantity 4x plus
3 squared and so we've just factored it
completely and the key realization here
is will 1 you know what can i factor out
from all of these terms I could factor
out an X from all of those terms and
then to realize that what we had left
over was a perfect square really using
this pattern that we were able to see in
previous videos